yeah I've been with a lot of uh
promiscuous gals in my day paid for a
couple of big old abortions that's a
thing you know I remember one time I
left the abortion clinic with a lady and
there's a guy protesting and he goes
you're a goddamn murderer I like I don't
know about murderer I really more just
hired a Hitman
man he was like well if it was up to me
you'd be in jail I'm like well if I go
to jail for this I want murderer status
I want to look tough you know all the
guys talking what are you in for Grand
Theft Auto assault and battery I'm like
murder they like damn who'd you kill I'm
like a
relative they're like whoa why'd you do
that I'm like I caught him inside my
girl I missed that girl she was fun she
was wild even after the abortion she was
like hey we should celebrate with a
drink I was like ah I don't think you
should drink on an empty
stomach